it is Christmas in October or at least
that's when big box stores want you to
start shopping for it so holidays
savings are all
officials saying it's the earliest
they've ever started reporter Ryan
Matthey joining us now live from a
shopping center on Maryland near
Flamingo with why right
Denise Brian we haven't even finished
our pumpkin spice lattes yet but those
big box stores are already dropping
those savings it's happening a full
month and a half before Black Friday
this year store officials saying they
saw some slow down within the past year
leading them to push those savings out
early this year
sharp till you drop
now earlier than ever Target Walmart
Kohl's Amazon just a few retailers wear
winter holiday savings have arrived
before Halloween October is super early
Brian Stanley is a Las Vegas calls
manager where holiday savings dropped
last week I have 20 25 people sitting
outside ready to kind of are you open
situation 30 off ten dollars off fifty
dollars extra coals cash all to get
consumers in the door sooner earlier
than he's ever seen it my family we want
to make sure we get it I think that
after last year there were some fears
the good news is I think we've got the
product form to come in and get early
some stores even allowing financing over
several weeks interest-free through new
Partnerships with buy now pay later
Services a recent consumer affairs
report also showing major retailers have
too much inventory following supply
chain shortages and hope better deals
will take it off their hands what
brought you into the store here today
months Shoppers taking advantage of the
deals whether for winter holidays or not
I shop all year round if I see something
for someone and it reminds me of them
then I'll pick it up and put it away and
give it to them whatever occasion comes
up
now for some of our old-fashioned
Shoppers they may actually pay to wait
several of these stores have even more
savings and discounts as we get closer
to Thanksgiving Black Friday Cyber
Monday even but store officials also
warn about waiting too late and actually
recommend people to get specific items
they want now before they sell out
reporting live at best on the boulevard
Ryan maffey 8 News Now